Nikolai Bondarenko is on a political diet.
For nearly a whole month now, the parliamentarian
from Saratov has based his food budget on
a local pensioners' living wage, spending
just 3500 Roubles – or around 46 Euros - to
eat.
The communist party politician only buys the
bare basics - and says he has been hungry
all month.
I decided to use my own example to prove that
living on 3500 roubles a month is impossible
without a negative effect on your health.
Some accuse the politician of populism, others
here at Saratov market thank him: Bondarenko
is pushing to double the living wage in Russia.
His campaign has gotten a huge amount of media
attention – along with us, a Russian federal
TV crew is also filming him preparing his
rations.
But to Bondarenko, this is more than just
PR and bigger than his health.
I'm convinced that a month on this diet isn't
enough to seriously damage a normal person's
health in the long-term.
Of course I have worried about my health.
But what I see across the country scares me
much more.
Bondarenko has documented the experiment on
his video blog – and also shows the debate
that kicked it all off.
Saratov's Labour Minister Natalya Sokolova
insisted the living wage is enough to guarantee
a balanced diet.
She was fired over the remarks
And Bondarenko’s argument has grown into
a national debate - even on state television.
But the government, including Saratov's new
interim minister for labor says the living
wage will stay the same for now.
The living wage is a substantiated sum, based
on statistical calculations - and on the law.
Of course we are striving to improve our approach
– in order to work out new, more effective
methods for calculating the living wage.
That work has begun and should be finished
in 2020.
Bondarenko’s experiment has struck a chord
beyond Saratov.
Across Russia, the standard of living has
been dropping consistently.
The Russian government has made halving poverty
a goal for the next six years.
Currently every eighth person in the country
lives under the poverty line – which means
they earn less than the living wage.
Food prices are going up, prices for bread
and milk are going up but the existence minimum
is still tiny.
I can hardly survive
You can only buy the cheapest products on
3500 thousand.
You can only exist on them, you can’t live.
At his office at the Duma, Nikolai Bondarenko's
phone has hardly stopped ringing.
The communist politician is convinced that
his words about the living wage will be heard
on a national level.
The only thing the government can’t control
is our solidarity on issues we can unite all
on.
The government is concerned about this – and
they'd rather lose a finger than a whole hand
Bondarenko is now preparing to take a draft
bill to the Russian Duma – he wants his
voice to be heard beyond the hallways of the
local parliament.